in this course you will learn all about
infrastructurist code i'll start by
giving you a general overview of the
different concepts and then i'll show
you how to implement infrastructure as
code with three different labs
this course will use python and aws but
the concepts will apply to other
languages and cloud providers
so let's start by talking about what
infrastructure as code is to put it
simply it's setting up your
infrastructure as code by infrastructure
i mean all the different things needed
to deploy your software into a cloud
environment
that can mean things like virtual
machines containers or serverless
functions
infrastructure also means all the other
pieces of infrastructure you need to set
up to make that successful
that can be security like aim and kms
or networking or some of the monitoring
and logging capabilities
you can also use code to configure and
set up data stores
these are the things that your
application needs to store and manage
data the last piece of infrastructure
landscape is the applications themselves
and getting the applications that we're
building into the infrastructure
all of these different pieces of
infrastructure can be set up using code
software as a service or sas
is related to infrastructure's code
software as a service allows users to
connect to and use cloud-based apps over
the internet
sas provides a complete software
solution that you purchase on a
pay-as-you-go basis from a cloud service
provider
you rent the use of an app or software
for yourself or for your organization
from a cloud service provider and
connect to it over the internet common
examples are email office tools crms and
development tools
infrastructure as a service is part of
software as a service infrastructure as
a service is a cloud computing service
where companies rent servers for compute
and storage in the cloud this allows
users to run operating systems or
applications on the servers without the
maintenance and operating costs of those
servers
so infrastructure as code involves using
code to manage your infrastructure as a
service
it's becoming more and more important to
automate infrastructure because
applications can be deployed to
production
up to 100 times per day and you don't
want to be doing that all manually
it's also helpful for infrastructure to
be provisioned or d provisioned in
response to load we need to answer
questions such as how do we get the
images for our vms
how do we get the container images in
how do we package up and ship code into
serverless functions
over the years there has been a
transition with how people are using
cloud infrastructure within their
organization
in the first wave it was fairly simple
the infrastructure were fairly static it
was often single virtual machines that
you just accessed through ssh
it got a little more complex in the
second wave
there were more containers and people
started using provisioning tools to
specify the application behaviors people
use things like docker and datadog
modern cloud infrastructure has added
way more complexity it uses containers
serverless and more managed services as
part of the applications
there are now way more different pieces
involved in how people build the
infrastructure
infrastructure as code is becoming a
more important part of how people build
and deliver applications because
infrastructure as code is what describes
the glue between all the different edges
on these diagrams this diagram for the
modern infrastructure may look more
complicated than the previous ones but
it can actually be easier to maintain
a key benefit is that the dark gray
squares in the diagram are the only part
which is the code you own
and that part is smaller than the
previous ways of doing things
so a lot of the operational burden has
been decreased compared to how it used
to be done
with infrastructure as code it is now
easier to build deploy and manage
infrastructure in a repeatable and
scalable way on a variety of cloud
service providers
infrastructure as code makes it easier
to manage that process alongside your
actual application code now there is a
greater focus on the glue between the
different services that are being
managed by a cloud provider and these
services can be deployed in a repeatable
and scalable way infrastructure code
takes on an increasingly more important
role in how you manage everything in the
modern cloud
so here are the three main ways that can
be used to manage all the resources
manual
that's how it used to always be done you
just point and click to create or modify
resources in the console you can do it
like through the aws console you can
just point and click to what things you
want to create
then there's ad hoc automation
this is when you use cli commands or
scripts to create and modify resources
so you're kind of using some code but
it's not going to be able to be reused
over and over and modified very easily
the third way is what we're talking
about infrastructure as code there's
provisioning which is declaratively
creating and modifying resources
and configuration which means to change
the state of an existing resource post
provisioning infrastructure as code
gives us the ability to write down what
we want the desired state of our
infrastructure to be i'll be showing you
how to do some of these things later
there are a few different ways to write
infrastructures code so one approach is
to use json
here's an example
you can see this is a way to tell aws
what resources you want to have
you can see the resources the ec2
instance
the instant security group and just
everything you're going to need just in
a json format
another method is to use domain specific
language or dsl
this is a custom method specific to the
tool or cloud provider you are using so
here's an example
you can see it does kind of look like
code but it's no no it's not like a
popular programming language or even the
exact way that json usually is written
yet another way of defining
infrastructure using code is to use a
well-known programming language for
instance polumi can be used to write
infrastructure as code using typescript
javascript python go and net
here's an example using typescript
and later we'll be using python
using code gives the ability to do
things that are not possible in some of
the other methods
in this example there's a for loop that
creates an instance for each
availability zone
code gives the ability to use loops
conditionals classes packages and more
using popular programming languages also
allows the use of common ides linters
and test frameworks
so let's get into some real world
examples
we're about to set up some actual
infrastructure as code there are a few
different services that allow you to use
popular languages to create
infrastructure as code in this course
we'll be using pollumi
this course was made possible through a
grant from blooming
pollumi is an open source infrastructure
as code tool for creating deploying and
managing cloud infrastructure
pollumi works with traditional
infrastructure like vms networks and
databases in addition to modern
architectures including containers
kubernetes clusters and serverless
functions
plumi supports dozens of cloud service
providers
we'll be using python and deploying on
aws
though it can be done with other
programming languages and cloud
providers we'll start with a simple
example
this will show an end-to-end experience
of working with plumi using very simple
resources
in this first example we'll do the
following
create a new project configure aws
provision infrastructure update
infrastructure make your stack
configurable create a second stack and
destroy the infrastructure we'll use an
s3 bucket and then work through the life
cycle with a simple set of resources
then in future examples you will learn
how to implement more complex things
with pollumi infrastructure is organized
into projects each project is a single
program that when run declares the
desired infrastructure for pollumi to
manage
before we start the first lab make sure
you have polomi installed
the way to install is different
depending on your operating system you
can check the link in the description
for all the instructions for how to
install different operating systems
one way if you have home brew is just
brew install
pollumi
like i mentioned we'll also be using aws
you have to make sure you have an aws
account and have the cli set up and
authenticated i have a link in the
description that shows you how to sign
up for a free aws account
also there's another link that shows how
to install the aws cli for your
operating system
from aws you're going to need an access
key id and a secret access key let me
show you how to get that
i'm at this url right here
um you can do without the v2 at the end
just the console.aws.amazon.com
iam
and then i'm going to go to users here
and then i'm going to add a user i'm
going to make a new user just for this
project
and the user is just going to be
infrastructure as code or iac
and i'm going to click that i want to
get the access key here
and next permissions
i'll just add administrator access so to
make sure it can do whatever needs to do
and then i'll just go through just keep
clicking clicking next and then create
user
okay now we have the amazon access key
and the secret access key
so you're going to actually have to copy
the access key and the secret access key
from this page and you can get that
obviously by clicking show to show the
secret access key let me show you where
you're going to need those things
go over to your command line and type in
aws configure
okay now this is where you're going to
enter your access key
i'm just going to copy it from here
and then the aws the aws secret access
key
now yours probably won't have this here
because i've already done that so it's
seeing if i want to use what i already
have but i want to put in a brand new
one here
and then we can just click none for the
next few things here
okay aws is set up
so the first step to starting a pollumi
project is to create a new directory
each pollumi project lives in its own
directory so i'm going to create one
first i'm going to go into projects
okay i'm gonna make a directory
and i'm just gonna call it iac
lab
one
now just jump into my directory i just
created
okay i'll do paloomi
new python because we're making a python
project and we'll just select yes to
everything
now i've already used pollumi on this
computer but if this is the first time
you've used pollumi you will be directed
to enter an access code or log in and it
will tell you the website to go to get
to get the access code but it's
app.paloomy.com
account slash tokens you will have to
create a plumi account and then you will
be able to get your access code
so this command has created all the
files we need it's initialized a new
stack named dev which is an instance of
our project we now need to install our
dependencies as part of our virtual
environment
so let's set up our virtual environment
we're going to create a virtual
environment and install the required
python packages the python module used
to create and manage virtual
environments is called v e and v so
let's use these commands first we'll do
python
3
m v e and v v e n v
and then source v e and v slash been
slash activate
okay i've activated my virtual
environment and now i'm going to install
the requirements pip 3 install
requirements
dot txt
that requirements.txt file was created
when we initialized our polumi project
now let's open this up i'm going to open
up in visual studio code but you can use
any code editor you want
okay these are all the files that got
installed when we did their pluminew
this main.pie is the program's main
entry point file this is the file that
we'll be putting all of our code in now
we have the requirements.txt
that's just your project's pip
dependency information
and then we have pollumi.yaml
which is the project's metadata
containing its name and language you can
see we have python and then we have the
name here and the virtual environment
so if we go back into the main.pi we'll
notice that we just have one line of
code that's just automatically put in
there which is import gloomy now there
could be more or less code in here
depending on
which way we run the plumi new command
but we just wrote ran it with plummy new
python so it just started with import
polymer which is the line of python so
now that we have the basic project let's
configure aws support for it
i'm actually going to open the terminal
right from within vs code okay i'm going
to install something so pip 3 install
pollumi
aws
now i'm going to
make our code
take up more of the room here and i'm
going to add another line so import i'll
import we just installed so import
pollumi
and actually recommend it right here
as aws
okay now we're going to configure an aws
region which is whatever region you want
to deploy to
by we're going to run something in the
command line so i'll go back down to the
command line and i'm going to do pollumi
config
set
aws
region
and you can use any aws region that you
like but in my case i'm going to use us
east
one okay now we're actually going to
start doing some infrastructure as code
we're going to provision infrastructure
so now that we have a project configured
to use adws we'll create some basic
infrastructure we'll start with a simple
s3 bucket so let's declare a new bucket
right up in our python file here i'm
going to say bucket
equals a
aws.s3 dot well s3 dot bucket
bucket
and then you can call anything you want
but i'm going to call it
my
bucket
okay i'm going to save this and we're
going to preview the changes so i'm just
going to go back to my terminal down
here and type in pollu me
up
so pluto me up is the command you'll be
running a lot with palumi which is going
to basically run our main.pi file and
set up our infrastructure how we
configured it so it looks like there's
an error here so let's see what that is
hmm looks like there was a mistake with
my aws login let me just try doing the
login again and see if that fixes the
problem
aws configure
now i'm going to get my access key
now try running pollumi up again
okay work this time
so let me
bring up this we can see more of what
the output was here
so this is a preview the command
evaluates your program determines the
resource updates to make and shows us an
outline of these changes so this is
what's going to happen we're going to
create this stack and we're going to
create this bucket here and it hasn't
done anything yet we can decide what we
want to do for now i'm going to go to
details to see more details
so you can see now we can see that the
acl
is private you can see the actual bucket
name we call that my bucket but plume is
going to add this at the end so we can
actually create a bunch of buckets with
the same name but it's just going to
have a different thing at the end here
and you can just see some extra details
about this and i do want to perform this
update so i'll just go to yes and okay
return
so now our s3 bucket has been created in
our aws account so if we view our
buckets on the aws website you'll see
the new bucket so i'm going to go to aws
and then go to the s3 section
and it's going to show this bucket we
just created
so it's currently empty but we can see
the bucket that we just created with
pallumi
and there's also this url here
if we go to this url i'll let's do uh
i'll just do command click
and i'm going to have to log into plumi
to get this to work out
so now we're on the plumi console which
records your deployment history so right
now we've just done one one thing so you
can see one thing on here
okay next i'm going to show you how to
export your new bucket name so
we're going to go back into the code
area
and to inspect your new bucket you'll
need its physical aws name well we did
see we were able to see the name
up here when we went to more details
but there's another way to get the name
that i will show you using the code
so
this
is called
the logical name my bucket but like i
said before the aws name will be a
little different
programs can export variables which will
be shown in the cli and recorded for
each deployment so let me show you how
to export the bucket's name by adding a
line of code in here so right after we
get the bucket here i'm going to do
pollumi.export
x
export
and then i'm going to export the bucket
name
so that's just what we're calling this
value which we're going to get as
bucket.bucket
so this bucket.bucket will be the bucket
name so let me just save this
and then we'll go back into the terminal
and i'll do pollumi
up
and now we can see
there's a new line here outputs
so
you can in your python code you can
export certain information that will
show up in the output section when you
do blue me up
so i'll just select yes to perform the
update
and you can see it's unchanged because
the only update was just to output the
bucket name here
you can see all the output
by running this command in the terminal
pollumi
stack output
you can see it's there's only one output
the bucket name and then it has the
value of it right here
now we can run the aws cli to list the
objects in this new bucket
and we can get the bucket name using the
command from above let me show you how
you do that so we're going to do aws
s3
ls and then
i'm going to run that command right in
here pollumi stack output
bucket
name so that's going to get the bucket
name
and if we run that command
nothing's going to really happen because
there's nothing in the bucket so it's
returning what's in the bucket but
there's nothing in the bucket so there's
nothing to be returned
but we'll change that shortly
we're going to now update the
infrastructure we just saw how to create
new infrastructure from scratch so now
we're going to make a few updates we're
going to add an object to the bucket
we're going to serve content from the
bucket as a website and we're going to
pragmatically create infrastructure
this will demonstrate how declarative
infrastructure as code tools can be used
not just for initial provisioning but
also subsequent changes to existing
resources so we're going to add an
object to the bucket i am going to
create a new directory i'm going to just
go to new folder i could click this
button up here this folder is going to
be called
site and then i'm going to make a new
file and this will be called index.html
okay i'm just going to make an extremely
simple website here html
and
body
and then just an h1 tag and it's going
to say
hello
everybody
okay now let me
rearrange things here we'll go back to
our main.pi
and let's add some lines of code so we
can add that file
to our bucket
so i'm going to add import
and put a new library the os library so
we can access
uh stuff from our operating system the
file path in particular
so
let's see actually we'll put it right
here
file path equals os dot path dot join
and then we'll put the directory name
site
and then the file name index.html
now we're going to create an object
variable
and we'll do aws.s3
dot bucket object
index.html
so the object is index.html
and then
the bucket
is going to be
dot bucket
and that's how you get the name of the
bucket that we created
and for source
i'll put polumi
file
asset
file
path
so this is how you use
polumi to get this asset this file path
right here we're going to create as the
object that goes into our bucket
so i'm going to save that and enter
terminal we'll do plumi up
and then i'll just
look at this
more
oh
not fire asset file
asset because this is a file asset
so i'll go to plume up
see that makes a lot more sense to you
doesn't it than fire asset okay so you
can see it's showing what the change is
going to be we're going to create this
object which is the index.html we're
going to create that
so i will go to yes to
do these changes perform this update
so a single resource is added and the
two existing resources are left
unchanged this is a key attribute of
infrastructure as code such tools
determine the minimal set of changes
necessary to update your infrastructure
from one change to the next
so
let's list again the contents the
contents of the bucket i'll just press
up a few times we'll use the same line
from before
and now let's see what's in the bucket
it's showing index.html and if i go back
over to my web browser
and if i refresh
my page that shows the bucket on aws
we should see yep we see this index.html
right here next step we're going to
serve content from the bucket as a
website
to do that we'll need to update a few
properties
first the bucket needs a website
property that sets the default index
document the index.html
that can
that can be achieved by making a few
changes to our python file
we have our bucket right here
and
i'm going to after the buck and nam and
add a comma
and then i'm going to put
website
equals
and then we just have to set the index
document
and we'll just set that to
index.html
and make sure that's in a string here
okay next
the index.html object will need two
changes
so let's go
down here to see this index.html object
that's right here
we're going to need an acl which is an
access control list of public read
so right after the source
i'll put
acl
equals
public
read
there now you can see that better
this makes it so it can be accessed
anonymously over the internet
we also need a content type so it's
served as html
so
for the content type to work
let's go back up to the top
we're going to import something import
mime types because we're going to set
the mime type
and then down here after the file path
we're going to get the mime type of the
file so mime
type
and what
we'll put it underscore because this is
going to return two things but we only
need one of the things which is the mime
type so we'll do mime types
dot guess
type
and we'll guess the type of the file
path
and now down here we can set the content
type
to
the mime type
so now we have the content type so it's
served as html
we'll also need to export the resulting
buckets endpoint url so we can easily
access it so let me show you how you
would do that
so here we're exporting the bucket name
and now let's export the bucket endpoint
the full url so we'll do pollumi
dot export
and this will be called the bucket
endpoint
we're going to use this concat function
from polumi to concat a string and
something else so this bucket.bucket
it's actually an object it's not a
string but it does return a string so if
we want to combine something like this
with a string we have to use uh concat
let me show you how that's done we're
going to do pollumi dot output dot
concat
and then i'm going to put the two things
we're going to concat the first thing is
going to be a string https came and see
what i'm writing here let's see if i can
http
let's do http
colon slash slash
and then we'll get a comma here
and
then just bucket dot web site
endpoint
so we're just concatenate we're
concatenating the http and this website
endpoint
okay let's deploy the changes so well
let me save it and then we'll do pollumi
up
if i go up here
we can see it's making some updates and
i'll go to yes
okay now we have this
url here so we can use this to access
that index.html file so i can actually
just copy this url stored on amazon aws
and now i can open up the url right in
my web browser it says hello everybody
i can also use curl to get it so back in
my terminal do curl
and
now i am going to run a command right
here to get the website url
lumi stack output and then you can get
any of the things that get output and
we'll get bucket
endpoint
okay see we got this
here's the text of our html file
next we are going to make the stack
configurable
right now the bucket's contents are hard
coded
we're going to make the location of the
contents configurable and add support
for populating the bucket with an entire
directory's worth of contents
so the next step is to add a config
variable
right now
we hard code the directory of the site
let me show you here so we have we're
hard coding
this directory here
of the site so we're going to configure
it to make it easy to change the
location without editing the program
so right below the imports here i'm
gonna do config
equals pollumi dot config
that's going to make it possible to
access some
config settings that we set up
and we're going to specifically access
the site
directory
and we're going to get it from
config dot
require
and then we're going to get the site
dir and i remembered i see that i
spelled paloomi wrong
there we go
and we are going to set this in a minute
the site directory but first let's
update our program to use this citer
variable so instead of getting the site
here i'm just going to paste in the
variable name okay so now what we're
going to do i'm going to save this and
then i'm going to go back into my files
i'm going to rename this site directory
i'm going to rename it
www now you may not actually do this in
like a real life situation but we're
just doing this as an example to see how
this can be helpful
so let me go into my terminal
and i'm gonna do pollumi
up
okay it's saying air missing required
configuration variable this site dur
variable and it says please set a value
using the command plume config set ic
lab 1 site directory with the value so
that's what we're going to do now i'm
just going to copy this command here
and then i'm just going to paste it in
and then i'm going to set it to www so
now the directory you'll be looking for
is the www directory instead of the site
directory
okay i'll just do plume up again
and i will perform the update
okay that works so now we don't have to
have the the directory hard hard-coded
in here we can use these config
variables and you can see how you'll be
able to use that with other types of
data as well okay now we're going to add
more files instead of hard coding the
set of files
which we do now let me show you what i
mean right now we hard code that we're
adding the index.html file
to our bucket but instead of doing that
we're going to change the program to
read the entire contents of the www
directory and add every file from that
directory to our bucket so let's start
by adding a new file to that directory
so i'm going to go into the directory
and click the new file button and this
is going to be called about.html and
this is just going to be a simple thing
you can make it anything you want i'm
just going to make an extremely simple
file with a paragraph it will say it's
about so i want to say something about
me and i am not a cat so that's
something about me
okay let's go back to the main.pi file
and we're going to replace the object
allocation code
and now we are going to update the
object
allocation code so this right here we're
going to put all of this into a for loop
so i'm going to say for file in os dot
list
directory
site
directory
and then i'm gonna just indent all this
so it's all in that directory
and see we have the the file here so now
instead of index.html
i'm going to put this variable file
so now we are using this for loop to go
through
every file and adding all those files to
our bucket now this is one of the really
cool things about infrastructure as code
and using an actual programming language
like python is that you can use for
loops and that can make things go a lot
that can make things a lot simpler and
save a lot of time like we didn't have
to use a for loop we could have just
copied and pasted this code a bunch of
times and and then added each file
individually in insta instead of using
this for loop but this is going to save
us a lot of time especially if we have
tons of files that we want to put into
our bucket
so let's go back to the terminal i'll do
actually have to save first here and
then i'll do pollumi up
so you can see what's going to do it's
going to create
this file this is about.html
and let's do that i'll go to yes
now i'm back in my web browser i'm going
to put a slash about
dot html at the end
and now we can see
i'm not a cat i can zoom in on that so
you can see a little better it's just a
paragraph tag so it's pretty small
we can also access it through curl the
same ways before
let me just press up in here but i'll
just put slash
about.html at the end
and then yep here it is here's the
about.html file we created
now we're going to create a second stack
it's easy to create multiple instances
of the same project in pollumi each
instance is called a stack
this is useful if you have multiple
development or test environments like
staging versus production or if you want
to scale a given infrastructure across
many regions
so let me show you how to create and
configure a new stack we'll create a
stack named prod so i'm
still in the terminal down here i'll do
pollumi stack and knit
prod
and i just created it now next i'll
configure the two required variables
the same ones we did before so we'll do
paloomy
config set
this is going to be the region aws
region
and we're going to do it different from
before this time it's going to be eu
west
one you can basically set this to any
aws region
we'll also set
the the site directory
paloomi config
set
iec
lab
one
site
directory
and instead of the www this is gonna be
www.prod
i'm just showing where you can have
different site directories for different
projects for different stacks
so let's see the list of stacks we have
paloomi
stack
ls
we have the dev stack
and we have
the prod or production stack
now let's populate the new site
directory we could have used the
existing www directory for the site
directory but for this example we'll use
the the www prod directory to
demonstrate how it can be configured
we will make a directory
wwe prod
and then i'm just going to create a file
right from here we could have created
the directory from here so where's our
new directory
right here i'll just create a new file
and it's just going to be another
index.html file
and
we'll just make it pretty similar let's
copy this other index.html file but this
time we're going to
add a paragraph tag here
and put
in production
so then we will be able to know the
difference between the production one
and the development one so just save
that
and then we'll just deploy the changes
plume
up
we don't need that up anymore
it says we need to set the command the
configuration variable apparently this
got set wrong oh it's because i call the
site
i made a mistake a long time ago where's
the side drill which should have been
site der so let's just go back over here
and
let's see
this is supposed to be site der
and i must of uh yeah so now let's try
this
pollumi
up
and then i'm actually going to also have
to
create the site the site der
configuration variable for the
development
stack but we're on the this we're on the
production stack now so let's keep going
with this
okay so we can see
the new buckets new objects it's
creating
and we can go to details just like
before
and you can see additional information
but i will just go to yes and perform
the update
okay let's try going to this url here i
click command click but i'm just going
to copy it
and then i'm going to go to my you
website here
hello everybody in production so we're
now seeing the production website
we can also curl it just like before
it's actually pretty much the same
command so if i just press up a few
times
and we see hello everybody in production
and especially when you're practicing
whenever you get to the end of what
you're doing you want to destroy
everything destroy the resources
this is especially important in aws you
don't want to accidentally be charged
something if you have stuff on aws for a
long period of time so
to destroy all the resources we can just
use pollumi
destroy
and that will make sure everything
gets destroyed
just like before it's going to show us a
preview and it's showing that it's going
to be deleting
all these things
three to delete
and yes i want to do that
and you'll see this message on the
bottom
the resource and the stack may have been
deleted
but the history and configuration
associated with the stack are still
maintained if you want to remove the
stack completely run pollumi stack
remove fraud which we do want to do so
paloomi
stack
remove
prod
and i'll just type in prod to remove
that but remember we have another stack
we have the dev stack so we're gonna
have to switch back to the dev stack
using pollumi stack select
dev
and then once we've
went back to that stack we can do
halloumi
destroy
and then i will say yes we want to
destroy that
and then we want to run this other
command again
gloomy stack remove dev
and type in dev
okay let's just verify that the stacks
are gone so i'll do pollumi
stack
list
and there are no stacks
okay we just completed the first lab the
next few labs are a little shorter and
demonstrate some more advanced tasks
the second lab is all about provisioning
ec2 virtual machines
amazon elastic cloud compute also known
as amazon ec2 is a web service that
provides secure resizable compute
capacity in the cloud it's designed to
make web scale cloud computing easier
for developers amazon ec2 simple web
service interface allows you to obtain
and configure capacity with minimal
friction so in this lab you'll first
create a single ec2 virtual machine
afterwards we'll scale that out to a vm
per availability zone in your region and
then add a load balancer to spread load
across the entire fleet
now we could do it all within the
directory we already created
and just update our python file just
remove everything from our python file
and start from scratch
but we'll create a new one to get more
practice we'll create a new directory to
get more practice so let me create a new
directory
called iac lab
2 and i'll go right into it cd iac lab 2
and then i'll just open that with my
code editor in this case visual studio
code
and before i initialize the project in
the terminal and then switch over to
code editor now i'll just initialize the
project right from the terminal within
my code editor so let me open up the
terminal
and we'll do pollumi
new aws python so this is a little
different from before
why
now we just have to make sure our
virtual environment is set up so do
python 3
then
then
and then source then
then activate
let's try putting an e at the end that
works better okay now let's install the
requirements
and let me configure the aws region so
plumi config set
aws
region
us
west
two and again you can use any region for
this
okay you can see the files here are
pretty much the same before we have the
requirements we have the yaml file
move this down
in the main.pi you can see this is a
little different we've already
initialized this with creating a bucket
and exporting the bucket
you can see the way we created this
with the plumey new
already added some some extra code
creating an s3 bucket
i'm going to do this a little
differently so i'm actually going to
delete all this and i'm going to import
pollumi
as aws
now we're going to dynamically query the
amazon linux machine we'll do this in
code and so that will avoid needing to
hard code the machine image
in other words it's ami ami is the
amazon machine image and that provides
information required to launch an
instance so let's get the ami with code
so ami
equals aws
dot ec
2
dot get
ami
and we want to get the most recent one
okay you can barely see that
okay mo so most recent we can set that
to true
and then i'm actually just going to
paste in some stuff here
everything's in the description all the
code and everything there's a link to an
article that will have all this code
but this allows us to set the owner of
the ami and some filters we want to use
so we also need to grab the default
virtual private cloud which is a service
that lets you launch aws resources in a
logically isolated virtual network that
you defined
that's available in our aws account so
to get that virtual private cloud we'll
just do vpc
equals aws.ec2.getv
and then we'll just set the default
to equal true
now we'll create an aws security group
this will enable ping over icmp and http
traffic on port 80.
so for this i will just paste it in
and we can see this is how you would
create a security group on here
and again you can get that code right
from the article in the description
now we're going to create a server
and this server is actually going to
have a startup script that spins up a
simple python web server i'm just going
to paste in some code and then i'll
explain it
so we're creating an instance of the
server we're creating a web server and
then this is the type a t2.micro
and this comes right from aws the types
of different servers that you can create
so you could do a t3 or t1 and there's
just different types you can do
and then we're getting the security
group ids right from what we already
created up here the group ids
and then the ami is from what we already
created and then this is an interesting
thing the user data
here we are creating a simple python web
server
now for most real world applications you
would want to create a dedicated image
for your application
rather than embedding the script in the
code like this
but for this example we're just trying
to spin up something really quick
okay now we are going to export the ec2
instances resulting i p address and host
name so we'll do pollumi
dot export
and then we're going to export the ip
and then server
dot public
ip we're getting the ip is coming
directly from aws here
and then the host name
which in this case is the public dns
okay we're going to provision the ec2
instance and access it so to provision
it we'll do pollute me up
wait first save save and then pollute me
up
and then let's see what it shows
looks like there's an air i think we
made a minor mistake here oh api that
should be ami
so let's save that
and then do blue me up again
okay and you can see it's showing what
it's about to create
and i'll just go into yes
okay if we go up we can see we have the
host name and the ip address
so i'm actually just going to take this
hostname and copy it we're going to go
right into our web browser so if i paste
it in here
okay it took a few seconds to start
working but it must have finished
provisioning so it says hello world
and another way to do is write from the
command line
interestingly it looks like a new
version of polumi must have came out in
the middle of me making this tutorial
because it wasn't saying that before
okay but right now i'm going to do this
curl
and do pull
pull me
stack output hostname
and then we can see the hello world
right here and i might as well just
install the new version of pollumi while
i'm at it
okay that was simple so the next thing
we're going to do is add more ec2
instances we're going to create multiple
instances that are each running the same
python web server and we're going to
make them across all aws availability
zones in the region
so let's go back up to our code
and the part of the code that creates
this web server
and this instance and it exports
resulting ip address and host name we're
going to
modify this a bit
well first of all we're going to make a
new there's going to be a new ip and
host name for each aws availability zone
so let's store those in in an array or a
list so ips
equals and then we're just making an
empty list that we're going to be
filling
host names
equals
and then we're going to put this into
a for loop because we're going to
make an instance for each element for
each availability zone so for a z and
aws dot get
of the availability zone we can get
right here
z
dot names
so for each availability zone
now what i'm going to do
i'm going to put this into the for loop
and then we'll just do some minor
updates
so this will be different for each
availability zone
so for where it says web server i'm
going to use the python f string
to put a variable in here
dash
a z
which is the availability zone
and then for the
well we'll add what the availability
zone is so i'll put
availability zone
and it's just going to be a z
and now we are going to make it so
each
and now we're going to make it so it
says hello world we're going to make it
so this is different the index.html
files can be different for each
availability zone so for that to work
let me just add a few characters here
and then we'll just do dot format
okay so now it's going to fill in the
availability zone uh for in this spot
here in the index.html file and we'll go
down here and the ip is going to be ips
and then we'll use that
variable and actually we didn't fill
that variable yet so we still have to do
that so host names
host names
and then right here still in the for
loop
ips.append
server dot public
ip
and then host names
append
server dot public
dns
okay so now we'll be exporting the list
of ips in the list of host names so
let's do another plug me up i'll save
that
and we'll do pollumi up
okay so we're going to be deleting our
original one and creating
four new ones if we go up here so
there's there's four of them for each
availability zone and you can see them
right here
west 2a 2b b2c and 2d
so i'll perform that update
okay it looks like we have an error the
requested instance type which is
t2.micro is not supported in the
availability zone but just this one so
i'm going to copy this and we're going
to use an if statement to make sure we
create an instance everywhere except
that availability zone so
if
not
a z
equals
us west d2
then
we'll create the server okay just let me
just indent all this here
and then i'll save it
pull me up
i'll go yes
okay now we have these three outputs
so i can just try going to one in the
web browser
and you can see this one is in
2a
let's try another one
and this one's 2b
so each web server is going to include
in the response what availability zone
it's in
but this isn't very realistic in the
real world you're not going to want all
these different urls for each
availability zone
we're going to now add a load balancer
the load balancer is going to be able to
distribute the load evenly we'll just
have a single url that we can go to and
the load balancer will automatically
determine which server or which
availability zone to get the data from
this is the way you can handle a lot of
people going to a website at once and
the website can be loaded from different
places depending on where the load is
the lowest so it can kind of balance the
load across all the servers
okay back over to our code we need to
add an egress rule to our security group
whenever you add a listener to your load
balancer or update the health check port
for a target group used by the load
balancer to route requests you must
verify that the security groups
associated with the load balancer allow
traffic to the new port in both
directions
so to do that
i'm just going to paste in the egress
here
this is required to ensure the security
group ingress rules don't conflict with
the load balancers
so now we'll define the alb let me go
right after this
security group definition
i'm going to add the load balancer
creation steps someone just paste in
some code here and i'll go over it
so we already have we already got the
vpc up here
but we also need the vpc subnets
and then we're going to create
the load balancer like this
we're gonna it's internal equals false
so it can be accessed by the public
we're going to use the same the group id
for the same security groups
and then the subnets we get right up
here
and then
we're creating a target group here
and then a listener
so we've defined the alb it's target
group and some listeners but we haven't
actually added the ec2 instance to the
alb
so this is how we're going to add the
instance let's go down to our creation
of the
ec2 the ec2 creation
was update this
to the security groups
and then we'll attach the instances
so we'll do attachment
equals aws.lb dot
target group attachment
and then this f string here
target group are in is going to be the
target group
dot arn
and the target
id
is going to be the server dot
private
ip
and then it's going to be on port 80.
okay we just want to export one more
thing
the
url
and this is going to be the main url
we're going to be using
which it has the load balancer
okay this is all the infrastructure we
need for our load balanced web server
so i'll just save that and we'll apply
it with polumi
up
and i'll perform the update
okay here is the load balancer url if i
just copy this
and i'm going to do a curl to it
now watch i'm just going to keep doing
it a few times and every time i do this
curl you can see that a different url is
loaded because c says
us west 2a 2c 2b 2b 2a so the load
balancer is working i have one url
but each time i go to the url it's being
loaded from a different server because
the load is being distributed
so
that works that's how you create a load
balancer
with infrastructure as code since we're
done with that i'm now going to destroy
everything since this is just a test i
don't want
these web servers still going on aws so
to destroy everything i'll just do
paloomy
destroy
and then i have to see do i want to
delete all this stuff
yes i do
okay just like it says here we can
also run this command plume stack remove
dev
to remove the stack completely
in this final lab we'll use pollumi to
deploy a docker image to ecs with
fargate
so let's start from the beginning again
to make more practice
so let me go out of this directory
and i'm going to create a new directory
and then i'll just change into it
and i will initialize
the project
okay we'll do pollumi new aws
python
and then i'll just fill this in or just
hit enter to use the default
so just like before it's creating all
the files we need it's initializing a
new stack named dev which is an instance
of our project
and it's installing the needed package
dependencies from pi pi
let's open up this in vs code
okay here's the project in nvs code the
same files from before we have the
main.pi
which is going to be our main file where
we put all the python code like before
and you can see down in the terminal
we're in our virtual environment
and let's configure the aws region now
it did do that when we were setting
things up but just to make sure we have
the right region pollumi config
set
aws
region
us west
2
and then we'll go back up to our code
and i'm actually just going to delete a
lot of this because we're going to start
from scratch we're going to start by
creating creating an ecs cluster so we
imported pollumi now let's import
plumy
aws
as aws
and now we'll create a new cluster
we can use the default values so it's
going to be pretty concise so cluster
equals
aws.ecs that cluster
cluster
now we're going to create a load balance
container service so we're going to
allocate the application load balancer
or the alb
and listen for http traffic port 80. in
order to do this we'll need to find the
default vpc and the subset groups for it
okay i'll just paste in some code here
and i'll just look through it i'm going
to go through it pretty quick a lot of
it's similar to the last lab we did
so we create the vpc and the vpc subnets
we got the security group here
there's the egress
and then we got the load balancer
and the target group
and the listener
so i'll save that and run plummy up
and then i'll make the update
so we've fleshed out our infrastructure
and added a load balancer that we can
add infrastructure to
in the next step we'll run a container
aws fargate is a service that enables a
user to run containers on amazon's cloud
computing platform without the need to
manage the underlying infrastructure
in order to create a fargate service
we'll need to add an iam role and a task
definition and service
the ecs cluster will run the nginx image
from the docker hub
so we're not actually going to create
our own docker image for this example
we're just getting the image right from
docker hub
so first we'll need to add an import at
the top of our file go to the top and
put import
json
now at the bottom i'm going to paste in
some more code here again it's all in
the description if you want to get the
code
so here we define our iam role and
attach a policy
so this section right here we're
defining the role here
and then we're going to attach this
policy
then we define a task definition for our
ecs service
you can see the image is the nginx image
and then here is the service
and then at the very end we export the
url
we get from here the alb
the dns name
so let's provision the cluster and
service
we'll i'll save
and then do pollumi
up
this is going to output the status and
resulting load balancer url
perform the update
so if i pull this up
we can see the status and the resulting
load balancer url
i'm going to copy this url and we're
actually going to try going to it in the
web browser
so if i load this it says service
temporary on the temporarily unavailable
but let's see if i refresh it a few
times
okay keep refreshing it eventually says
welcome to nginx
we got the web server
says if you see this place the nginx web
server is successfully installed and
working
we can also go to the terminal and do
this curl plume stack output url so it's
just going to actually just curl that
url
and you can see we have the same html
that we saw in our web browser
that the nginx web server successfully
installed
so now let's update the service
we're going to change the desired count
from 1
to 3.
so now we are making three containers
save that
and then i'll do pull me up
and then i'll say i want to update
i'm over on the aws console and if i go
to the ecs clusters page and i make sure
i have the right region in here the one
that i set up
for my on polumi we can see the cluster
that i created we have one service it's
running two tasks
so desired test three and it's running
two
so we can see the desired count up here
is three
just like we set up in pollumi
okay we're actually done with this so
we're going to destroy everything
pollumi destroy
and yes
okay then we'll remove the stack
completely with pollumi
remove dev
okay we're done with the third lab
thanks for watching i hope this spurred
your interest to start trying to use
some infrastructurized code on some of
your own projects